come to this wedge first what you guys
want to hear a rap about sex how
exciting um people always shout out here
not with me obviously I'm married I you
can we can get a different one or you
can be more specific delve into alike
the dangers of unsafe sex or sex around
the back of a nightclub in a bin sex on
a tractor okay some farmers down there
I'm all the way from Iowa to the show
it's gonna be good sex on a tractor I
like this rectangular section here what
would you guys like a rap about
sustainability yeah
such a Californian crowd sustainability
sex on a tractor this tranche here what
you guys gonna suggest aliens and what
did you say gingivitis Wilson will take
aliens with gingivitis sex an attractor
sustainability alien gingivitis final
Trivial Pursuit wedge what are you guys
gonna suggest Spanish influenza
save the best to last like that sex an
attractor sustainability alien
gingivitis Spanish Influenza so far
these are really good and I'm not
kidding with you about that we're gonna
take one final one let's make this the
best of the best the crème de la creme
was that horseshoe lovely lovely you're
smiling so sweetly I'm very horseshoe
horseshoe sex on a tractor alien
gingivitis sustainability Spanish
Influenza this lovely people of the
comedy magic club in Hermosa Beach is a
little treat for you guys little thing
called a freestyle rap that is a rap
made up on the spot based entirely on
your suggestions it's not read is not
rehearsed and do not worry it will not
be anywhere near as atrociously
embarassingly toe-curling ly bad as you
are expecting a twenty nine-year-old
privately educated middle class white
english boy to be should we drop that
beat Spanish Influenza early gingivitis
sustainability sex on a tractor in
horseshoes I am very excited I hope you
are too let's see how it goes
the final suggestion for first one nerd
I do I'm sitting on a hoof you can call
me horseshoe I will carry the horse
every single where I go to the farrier
together exchange when I know Bernie
needs to be changed because it's where
we're through it's so annoying that you
can't recycle those horseshoes get the
half nail on my big shire horse the most
important thing sustainability of course
I gotta get to Philly and make it
sustainable gotta keep a male cow going
sustainable but if you wanna do
something that is so vital maybe throw
away the glasses get the paper recycle
although these they're gonna help you
save some - because the people wants
they crumble when you give the washed is
a one thing I've never thought of before
I get annoyed when we're sustainable
with no plastic straws the paper ones
are useless they turn into mush I know
it's very sorry and we cry and we gosh
when we
see a sea turtle with the straw up its
toes but I don't even mind if the sea
turtles go extinct what I think always
being so mean let's vote for a deal get
a new on that screen is splits the
electorate every single way here's a
real problem back in the day yeah you
get a toothbrush I advise you try this
taking in a UFO brush for gingivitis get
that gum disease away you really need
that to succeed if you can't bleed you
heed that advice it leads to heart
disease and clots in your arteries when
I see an alien the first thing I will
answer please take me to your leader no
I will resist I'll say come little green
man to the dentist I'll take you over
there the fun has begun sit down in the
chair let's examine you gums oh I think
your hygiene is not okay because the
gums aren't pink like your skin they
gray and not being racist when I save
this I have sex in the farmyard I'm not
the chase this guy that you'll ever see
I'm so attractive when I'm kicking back
straw hat on the tractor all the
farmhands gather round smooth as silk
and they squeeze on my genitals like
they are trying to milk a cow they say
wow I've never had Gouda and I say
better as they milk like an udder on a
tractor you can see me up here doing
reverse cowgirl riding on a John Deere
what a fun pin all of my jobs here
everybody's excited tap in the chair the
one last thing that I need to do I
spread a new STP it's the Spanish flu
but it is between gonorrhea syphilis and
all the rest
Spanish flu put your immune system to
the test there's only one place where we
haven't got on here's a fact if you're
in Colorado Gunnison they didn't get the
Spanish flu they quarantined it off no
one was allowed there if they had a
cough they would get you in the
outskirts burn you on a stake Spanish
flu is such a bad thing if you take into
your lungs
you'll die yet you will kids and it
comes from where Spain probably Madrid
there you go
[Applause]
much obliged